we begin this morning with dr. Christine
Blasi Ford asking for more time to make
a decision about testifying before the
Senate Judiciary Committee the
committee's chairman Senator Chuck
Grassley tweeting just before midnight
said dr. Ford if you have changed your
mind say so so we can move on Grassley
had set a deadline last night of 10
o'clock for Ford to make her decision
earlier in the evening as that deadline
approached a lawyer for four called it
arbitrary and said quote its sole
purpose is to bully dr. Ford president
Trump is spending the weekend at his New
Jersey Golf Club we Jing is traveling
with the president we do good morning oh
good morning everybody dr. Ford's
attorney says her clients spent several
hours with the FBI yesterday to deal
with the recent death threat she's been
receiving and she needs one more day to
make her decision when senator Grassley
says he's already given her one five
times but added he wants to hear her
testimony meanwhile President Trump has
already indicated who he believes he was
born for the US Supreme Court President
Trump did not mention dr. Christine
Blasi Ford by name at a campaign rally
in Missouri last night but he didn't
have to as he defended Judge Brett
Kavanaugh we have to fight for him not
worry about the other side and by the
way women are for that more than anybody
would understand
Ford claims when they were both in high
school a drunken Kavanagh put his hand
over her mouth at a party and groped her
which he denies Senate Republicans and
White House advisors has used a measure
tone when talking about Ford let her
tell her story on
here in Washington just minutes after
Kellyanne Conway made those remarks
yesterday the president tweeted about
Ford's allegation writing if it was as
bad as she says either her or her loving
parents would have filed charges
immediately I was appalled by the
president's tweet Maine senator Susan
Collins is a key Republican still
undecided on Kavanagh what I want is for
both dr. Ford and Judge Cavanaugh to
come to the committee and testify under
oath
Ford requested an FBI investigation but
the President refused to order one
Republicans on the Senate Judiciary
Committee moved forward with their own
CBS News obtained this email they sent
to a woman who may have been in
attendance at a party that occurred
circa 1982 requesting a confidential
phone call Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell told the crowd at a
conservative summit in DC there's
nothing to worry about
judge Kavanagh will be on the United
States Supreme Court Grassley says that
he has given dr. Ford until this
afternoon to decide whether she will
testify he says it's not his normal
approach to be so indecisive and to give
so many extensions adding on Twitter I
feel like I'm playing second trombone in
the Judiciary Orchestra and Schumer is
the conductor Michelle interesting Lita
Jane thank you